mainstream TV viewers often Overlook
horror but American Horror Story managed
to seduce an audience all its own here's
a look behind the scenes into what it
took to bring the Beloved Anthology
series to the small screen before
American Horror Story debuted in 2011
co-creator Ryan Murphy was best known as
one of the minds behind glay a show so
happy and positive that it was literally
about a bunch of high school kids
gaining self-esteem by singing and
dancing to familiar pop songs Murphy
then went directly from his High School
Musical to a house full of ghosts
violence and a rubber man what happened
who hurt you Ryan in an interview with L
Murphy admitted I was like I can't write
any more nice speeches for these Glee
kids about love and tolerance and
togetherness to that end he wrote a show
about horror and depravity instead
American Horror Story also allowed
Murphy to write a Glee wrong it wanted
Sarah pulson to play Emma Pillsbury the
high school guidance counselor
eventually portrayed by JMA ma pson was
enabled because she was starring in a
Broadway play at the time Murphy finally
found a place for Paulson as medium
Billy Dean Howard the first of many
memorable AHS roles she would step into
so much pain
here so much
longing and
regret while occasionally Cy and Darkly
funny most every season of American
Horror Story gets pretty bleak pretty
quickly I mean just because you got 30
bodies buried in your crawl space don't
mean you can't have a really terrific
recck room and be a respectable
businessman playing murderers and their
victims can really get under the skin of
the actors so a few have tried to
relieve the tension when possible
Zachary Quinto took on a major role in
Asylum as Oliver thredson another role
he accepted on set music therapist
playing as banjo on set to lighten the
mood Lily RAB plays guitar in real life
and should play to provide musical
breaks on tough days too yeah musical
breaks it was it's it was good Zach is
better at the banjo than I am at the
guitar for sure Jessica Lang the Grand
Dame of American Horror Story convinced
Ryan Murphy to put one of those melodic
pallet cleansers into the show itself
after a flashback revealed that her
Asylum character had once been a singer
in a band Lang suggested a full-on
fantasy musical sequence in the middle
of a psychiatric institution set to the
Classic 60s novelty song The Name Game
if only because as she told vulture
everything we do is so grim before it
was cancelled in 2017 scream Queens Ryan
Murphy's other other show was the place
where the blood and gore of American
Horror Story met the comedy of glay for
instance its first season asked a
burning question how might a cast made
up of self-absorbed sority girls and
dumb Frack guys deal with a costume
serial killer roaming their College
COMPASS good evening idiot hookers I'm
very happy to welcome you to Hell Week
here at Kappa house it was also laced
with references to Classic slasher
movies Tong and cheque horror movie
tropes and it even starred Halloween's
Jam Lee Curtis in a major role while
that male sound pretty standard for the
guy who conjured up the dead Breakfast
Club scream Queens nearly had even more
in common with American Horror Story
just how much you ask well it was almost
a spin-off of coven the AHS season sets
it a school for young witches in New
Orleans
surpris I bet you thought you'd seen the
last to me however Murphy changed his
mind after a lunch with Fox Executives
explaining we were talking about things
that we loved that were not on the air
things that we loved growing up movies
that we loved watching Once the subject
of slasher movies came up scream Queen's
own unique identity began to take shape
and while its ride was a short one it
sure was a blast while it
lasted in the months before the sixth
season of American Horror Story
premiered in 2016 effects released more
than 20 teasers each suggesting a
totally different theme at a television
critics Association event effects CEO
John langra explained that only one of
them accurately represented the season
while the rest were misdirects though
wildly different the trailers did share
a few things in common all of them were
creepy weird and pretty damn unsettling
perhaps none more so than the one that
showed a woman using some hedge clippers
to snipper Windchimes made from human
teeth turns out that was a trailer as
that imagery figures into American
Horror Story Rowan Oak in a way though
all of the fake trailers were real That
season of the show explored the Notions
of real and fake as the plot centered in
part on a couple who lived in a haunted
house near the Lost Colony of Rowan Oak
and the TV shows Recreations of the
events he enured at the hands of the
ghostly Rowan Oak colonists in American
Horror Story Hotel Evan Peters portrayed
Mr March who turns out to be arguably
the most Super Evil character character
in the show's long list of Super Evil
characters I look around and I see the
definition of American success why well
because he trapped tortured and killed
people in the hotel Cortez duh it's
quite upsetting then that according to
Ryan Murphy in Entertainment Weekly Mr
March is based on a real person that
individual is HH Holmes who during the
Chicago World's Fair in 1893 opened and
ran a hotel of Horrors visitors to the
great exposition who tragically chose to
stay at homes's hotel would find their
rooms soundproofed and windowless all
the better for homes to take them out
via gasing or other means secret
passageways allowed him to remove bodies
to the basement without detection where
he'd destroy the evidence in a furnace
he was caught in 1894 and executed 2
years later in addition to Legendary
Oscar winners like Jessica Lang and
Kathy bats American Horror Story has
made stars of upand comers like Emma
Roberts and Evan Peters and proved to
the world long before A Star is Born
That Lady Gaga could act it's hard to
believe that some performers couldn't or
didn't want to be involved with the top
rated show Chris zilka booked a two
episode stint on Asylum as a deaf man
but a few months later he exited because
he didn't want to shave his head a
requirement of the role Ryan Murphy has
also dutifully pursued a few Dreamcast
members albeit unsuccessfully among the
targets he has revealed Michelle Fifer
Michael chicklas and Reese Witherspoon
talking about the latter to
Entertainment Weekly Murphy said I
wanted her to play something really
twisted and effed up but she's always
booked Neil Patrick Harris and his
Husband David berka appeared in freak
Show although Murphy earlier pursued the
couple for murder house he wanted them
to portray the bickering pair ultimately
played by Zachary Quinto and Teddy Sears
Harris explained to Rolling Stone why
they skipped out on the par referring to
the couple's roles in a very Harold and
Kumar 3D Christmas we had just played
ourselves as a couple not getting along
I thought it just seems weird to do that
twice as indiv idual actors to play a
couple that hate each other twice so I
said no that we shouldn't do it the
eighth season of American Horror Story
dubbed apocalypse tied together
characters from multiple seasons in the
ultimate crossover event to face the
ultimate Evil Michael langon The
Offspring of Satan the Antichrist in the
sixth episode of The Story return to
Murder House viewers learned that
Michael realizes his evil abilities in
full after a visit from Anton LA and his
top lieutenants who ritually and
brutally sacrifice a woman remove her
Beating Heart and give it over to the
young embodiment of true evil to Feast
upon it was a deeply upsetting scene for
many viewers but in a different way for
the Real Life Church of Satan Anton Le
was a real person who really did found
the Church of Satan and wrote several
books espousing the beliefs of the
10,000 strong organization present day
Church of Satan leaders objected to the
portrayal of the church on American
Horror Story tweeting about their
disapproval in October 2018 and and
pointing out the inaccuracies in the
adaptation when Ryan Murphy talked to
The Hollywood Reporter regarding Sarah
Paulson's portrayal of bet and Doc
Tattler during the fourth season of
American Horror Story he couldn't hold
back his overwhelming praise saying it's
absolutely the most challenging thing
I've ever seen any actor do ever it was
really terrifying as you might imagine I
didn't know how in the world we were
going to do it and um it's a really
scary thing to to act by yourself the
dual role found Paulson playing
conjoined twins with two heads and one
body living in a traveling Sideshow on
American Horror Story freak Show it was
also one of the most challenging things
the show's special effects artists ever
had to attempt it required a lot of
old-fashioned trickery labor and digital
manipulation for pson to convincingly
play both characters first the effects
team took a mold of Paulson's own head
and use it to build two sophisticated
prosthetic heads as Murphy explained so
when Sarah is doing her coverage with
where she's do she has on a fake head to
her left which is BET and it moves she
literally has to do scenes with herself
those scenes took as long as 15 hours to
shoot because everything with the
tattlers had to be filmed for close-up
in medium shots for effects and from
various angles
twice American Horror Story freak Show
takes place in Florida among the
denisons of one of the few remaining
Cabinet of Curiosities shows in 1952 a
highlight of the season is the recurring
motif of
anacronismo meaning characters set in
the show's world of the early 50s sing
very famous songs recorded decades later
Ryan Murphy explained that the songs
were carefully selected for freak Show
and for good reason as he explained we
decided we only were going to highlight
musical artists who at some point in
their career had identified themselves
as feeling like freaks or Misfits or
outcasts which our people are going
through
American Horror Story Hotel took
inspiration in part from the ghastly
Horrors committed by HH Holmes and
seemingly from something more modern and
ambiguous as well the hotel Cortez is
Loosely based on the cesil hotel a
structure in the skid row area of
downtown Los Angeles that's hosted
countless tourists and transients as
well as murderers and Mysteries Austrian
serial killer Jack uner resided at the
hotel for a while as did Richard Ramirez
the murderer known as the nightstalker
he's even a character at American Horror
Story Hotel the one incident that really
moved the needle for American Horror
Story Creator Ryan Murphy was the story
of Alisa lamb as explored in the 2021
Netflix documentary crime scene The
Vanishing at the cesil hotel Canadian
student lamb stayed at the CLE during a
trip to Los Angeles in 2013 only to
disappear an internet driven Manhunt
ensued especially after the release of a
bizarre surveillance video of lamb
acting erratically in a Cil hotel
elevator a few few days later Lamb's
body was discovered in a rooftop water
tank Murphy summed up the puzzling
circumstances at a television critics
Association event in August 2015 a girl
got in an elevator in a Downtown hotel
she was never seen again the Sinister
sounding post-modern opening sequence
for American Horror Story seems tailor
made for the show a combination of
spooky forbidding and hypnotic musical
themes punctuated by jarring jump scare
sounds surprisingly the bulk of it comes
from a 20-year-old class project back in
1998 Cesar Dila isari was a sophomore at
the University of Puerto Rico for a
music history class he created A
Primitive digital audio track using Cool
Edit 96 on his Windows 98 computer
stretching mixing and combining various
sounds with white noise for example the
song's first dissonant moment comes from
a clip of Dila aari dropping wire
hangers on a tile floor when he was done
Dila aari gave it to his friend
Gabrielle Diaz who went on to work as a
video editor on the first season of
American Horror Story he used Aila
aari's track as a placeholder but
producers liked it so much they decided
to keep it for Technical and legal
reasons show composer Charlie cler of
9in nails recreated and spruced it up
with Dila zari's blessing apart from a
couple of appearances as Church of Satan
Cardinal Samantha crow in the apocalypse
season actor Naomi Grossman left her
mark on the American Horror Story
franchise in the second season Asylum
story she portrayed pepper a woman who
suffers from microsopy which means
someone having a smaller than normal
head she also possesses many other
notable physical traits such as large
ears jutting teeth a mostly shaved pain
and a top knot Grossman is almost
unrecognizable as pepper and her
physical transformation into the
character for each episode of Asylum was
a long and involved process with
Grossman telling Entertainment Weekly
the entire process takes about 2 and 1/2
to 3 hours and that's with two men
working the entire time freckles and
veins were drawn on Grossman's skin and
then came extensive Prosthetics which
included a forehead complete with
punched in eyebrows a nose ears and even
a bumpy little spine piece for my back
Grossman was also outfitted for a set of
false teeth which altered the shape of
her mouth and face Grossman additionally
revealed that she couldn't even use one
of her eyes thanks to a lens she had to
wear songs recorded by Fleetwood Mac as
well as that band's Stevie Nicks
permeate the soundtracks of multiple
American Horror Story Seasons That's
logical as NYX has long been associated
with witches dark spirits and other
spooky stuff that's abundant in the Ryan
Murphy horror Anthology nyx's bewitching
presence is felt most strongly in the
third American Horror Story subtitled
coven where Lily RAB plays a witch who
deeply loves nx's music even before she
finds out the singer is an actual
practicing witch too NY makes a cameo
late in the season and it was tough for
American Horror Story producers to make
it happen Nix was friendly with AHS
creators Ryan Murphy and Brad falchuk
having lent a hand on a Fleetwood Mack
tribute episode of their series Glee for
American Horror Story NYX told the Los
Angeles Times that the creators asked if
they could use her music again and when
they explained that her songs were an
integral aspect of the Lonely character
Misty day Nicks acessed when Murphy
asked her to appear she was terrified At
first she had a terrible time acting in
a fourth grade play and had quote vowed
to stay away from acting Forever This
sha has danced across the stages of the
world and now it's
yours and good luck with the Seven
Wonders each year the story setting and
characters are different but the actors
remain the same from the beginning of
the American Horror Story Anthology
concept Creator Ryan Murphy has utilized
a collective of performers with many of
them dutifully returning for each
successive season however when it came
time to shoot season 9 19 1984 Murphy
had to make do without the use of some
of his most venerable actors for example
Evan Peters starred in8 Seasons then
left the show citing burnout and an
aversion to getting typ cast in horror
roles Sarah pson also appeared in each
of the first eight tales and jessal Lang
bowed out after four seasons then had a
small role reprising cameo in the eighth
season which tied together several
different desperate American Horror
Stories together it also involved a
large number of actors which stretched
fx's budget with FX CEO John landra
telling the rap it was a monster in
terms of the size of the cast cost of
that cast according to langri Murphy had
to quote clean the Slate start over when
American Horror Story 1984 debuted it
boasted a cast composed mostly of new
and Latter-Day rals to the
franchise after the soft reboot of
American Horror Story was announced in
the form of an 80s horror movie
influenced season called 1984 a series
fan and video editor named Cory Vega
made a preemptive cut of what he thought
the upcoming episode's opening credit
sequence ought to look like in short
Vega thought it should look extremely
80s he put together a rapid fire clip
Montage that included shots of aerobics
instructors neon-colored cars
moonwalking and neon graphics and
because it's supposed to be an American
Horror Story clip lots of blood and gore
permeated it all the video spread around
the internet until it reached a very
influential figure co-creator and
producer Ryan Murphy Murphy wrote on
Instagram that he was such a fan of the
edit that he hired Vega to recreate his
video with AHS titles designer Kyle
Cooper to use in
1984 lots of people have a fear of
clowns known as Cobia it must be
something about their Frozen exaggerated
and untrustworthy grins or how their
identity is concealed under white face
paint American Horror Story aptly
exploited those fears in its freak Show
season featuring John Carol Lynch as the
Monstrous Twisty the Clown who isn't so
much a children's party Entertainer as a
guy who kills people with scissors and
locks kids in an old school bus perhaps
unsurprisingly this subplot upsets some
real life clowns as clowns of America
president Glenn Colberg said in a
response to freak Show in 2014 Hollywood
makes money sensationalizing the norm
they can take any situation no matter
how good or pure and turn it into a
nightmare we do not support in any way
shape or form any medium that
sensationalizes or adds to chorophobia
the protests flared up again in 2017
when American Horror Story cult once
again featured evil clowns World Clown
Association president Pam Moody told the
Detroit Free Press the role of a clown
Persona regardless of their style of
clowning is meant to bring joy and
laughter to bring humor to a hurting
world